[Music]
okay so it's probably like acid rain
probably should be back I've always
known that I've wanted to have kids but
when I start thinking about the fact
that my mom was already pregnant by the
time she was 30 it gets me into this
headspace where I started getting
nervous and start feeling like I have a
finite amount of time so I want to talk
to the wisest woman I know
my mom okay I'm leaving my house for
Atlanta to go to the airport and my cats
are not happy no okay so we just landed
in Atlanta and my skin just feels really
dry so I'm going to miss myself no good
morning Wow
when I'm at home I like to pamper myself
just because I feel like I can really
let my guards down do your towel right
now what is it
or stablish glow boost clay sticks can
you believe that I came out of your body
30 years ago it's crazy to think about
we're approaching different chapters of
our life because I'm turning 30 in
December and then your guarantor attire
feels like there may be more face masks
in our future do you have to come home
yeah oh yeah that glow is real that glow
is real all right let's go do more fun
things today
okay mom is in the process of cleaning
out her mom's house and Busha my polish
grandmother collected a bunch of costume
jewelry we're gonna go through it and
figure out which ones we're gonna keep
for funsies and which ones we are gonna
donate I'm coming to terms with the fact
that I'm turning 30 it makes me feel
really old a lot of people in my
generation get married in their 30s a
lot of people in my generation decide to
have kids in their 30s does it weird you
out that I'm turning 30 and I'm not
married or even close to getting married
okay why you
and that's all that matters to me and
you know if you force something like
that it's never gonna work out you
waited a long time to have kids yeah we
did
did you feel pressure from well I ignore
pressure I was gonna do what I was gonna
do thanks for sharing that with me cuz
that meant a lot to me and you mean a
lot to me and if I didn't show that to
you who wouldn't show it to nobody else
cares about the service that's my
husband doesn't going home and chatting
with my mom I think it just gave me the
peace of mind to be myself and my 30s
for a minute before I even approach this
question because my mom never ever ever
asks me when are you gonna have kids she
never asks about like when I'm getting
married she's just happy to see me happy
and successful sometimes going home you
just learn stuff about yourself that you
didn't know that you needed to hear not
so - like so glad I'm not pregnant
not ready he's still not ready not ready
not ready
[Music]